ET Aie
et
avoir dans
France en
la fois où je ne sais pas ça
la vie est revenue
pour aujourd'hui
pas du tout
née
rien n'est que confiance
et crée les Bonanças
le nouvel amour dans la jeunesse Jésus est comme
à voir
j'ai passé la maladie
comme jamais votre
roue de la vie
temps de roue
chante chante comme qui P dream va
Enceinte
et
Je l'ai supplié de la vie
temps de roue
cette attaque est frite qui dans un rêve va à
mener
l'enfant chante
et la vie est enchantée
Quel
merveille rappelez-vous rêver ne sais pas
toujours
donnant
amour
le sentiment
première
que le soleil de la nature offre un
et dans ta générosité
n'est peut être pas
passager
tu le gardes dans ton pinceau
Durée de vie de la roue
temps de roue
chante chante comme ceux qui ont un rêve
la vie
roue roue fille
temps de roue
chanter chante le vent
de rêve Gabi vie et
le
roue de la vie
temps de roue
chanter chanter comme un rêve
valide
Durée de vie de la roue
temps
chante chante vu que je suis
vas y donne un
ET Aie